man wasn't a very good job for us dr.
Robert Redfield was totally misquoted in
the media on a statement about the fall
season and the virus totally misquoted
the president demanded the director of
the Centers for Disease Control walk
back his warning about a second wave of
coronavirus uncomfortably Robert
Redfield did not do so disputing the
headline above the initial interview but
confirming he had been accurately quoted
I didn't say that this was gonna be
worse I said it was gonna be more
complicated because we'll have flu and
corona virus circulating at the same
time the president sought support from
another of his medical experts dr.
deborah birx the great thing is we'll be
able to find it earlier this time and I
think that's what we're talking about
we'll find those cases earlier so what
dr. Redfield said we would be able to
stay in containment phase President
Trump continued to push back against
potential future threat and an answer to
a reporter's question argued the virus
may not come back at all what it is
estimated might not come back at all
Jeff it may not come back at all
he's talking about a worst case scenario
where you have a big flu and you have
some Corona and if it does come back
it's not gonna come back and I've spoken
to ten different people not gonna be
like it was apparently one of these ten
people the president spoke to was not
the country's foremost medical expert
dr. Antony thought she was adamant there
would be a second wave of the virus
later this year there will be corona
virus in the fall if we do which we
won't but let's take an imaginary period
we said okay for ours forget about it
we're not gonna do anything about it it
will take off that's what viruses do but
that's not what's gonna happen we're
gonna respond to it to not allow it to
do that early on Wednesday President
Trump planted a tree marking Earth Day
but given the disagreements that played
out in the evening briefing his medical
experts could well fear that he's also
planting the seeds of misinformation
Mike Hanna al Jazeera Washington